estamos en cali nov acá una pequeña
ciudad que en tiempo normal queda a más
o menos 3 horas en carretera al suroeste
de que esos voluntarios preparan
blindajes para el ejército otros mandan
paquetes de alimentos que regala la
población local sólo hay mujeres aquí
porque los hombres están llamados al
frente todo el mundo se está movilizando
incluso mi padre va a ir cada uno hace
lo que puede nosotros apoyamos y hacemos
lo que podemos pero si no nos ayudas
ellos serán los siguientes en atacarte
es cierto
queremos que occidente nos ayude porque
la ayuda llegó muy tarde demasiado tarde
se hubieran introducido sanciones en el
2014 todo sería diferente
putin no habría empezado esta guerra y
ahora es un poco tarde pero más vale
tarde que nunca
no podemos vivir bajo el control de otro
país así que solo tenemos la opción de
elegir entre la victoria o la muerte
lucharé como un samurai y puede que me
maten pero no viviría bajo el mando de
putin viviré en un país libre si han
escogido este lugar para trabajar es
porque en el edificio de atrás el azul
hay un refugio y los tiroteos se hacen
escuchar hasta aquí